attention ici le téton a déjà vu je suis
d' orlando 1
vous devez dire du mal des habitants du
pas de calais comme je connais pas je
ferai les cas les jurys à notre sens
déjà difficilement vous dire qu'on fait
c'est quelque chose que vous avez sur le
coeur à la peur d'être les seuls
étrangers ici en train de parler la
langue maternelle
oui vous êtes mais ni ces rabbins ne
vous aide à gérer je connais bien votre
histoire mais bien vous êtes un des
puits des puits et l'otan se sont
enrichis milan qu'il avait cure je vais
faire comme un messie ramon j'irai
choisir il a choisi de chanter moi parce
que non non non je parle j'ai réduit un
point m
je voudrais tant que tu te souviennes ce
temps là où nous étions amis en ces
temps là la vie était plus belle île et
soleil puis bien qu'aujourd'hui les
feuilles mortes se ramassent à la pelle
pourquoi je peux pas oublier l'effet
mortes se ramassent à la pelle les
souvenirs et les regrets
dieudonné
tu essaies de le marier
non un truc une chanson brésilien
l'amour dans les ten 1
d'ailleurs une chanson moyens tant
bonite moyens navigon mano vocation
inkatha foudroie moore ink adam ou
robert herbin droit mourra jamais
et en vendangeant touche quintin ou soda
moyens qui ma soeur ou 10 h afin et ôter
au lido yart b agnès jaoui
je